i'd say that the worst thing about
being a writer or a creator is the lack
of stability
if we were going to take the same new
screenwriter and
they asked well how do i know i have a
yes person
who might be reading my script so it's a
person who doesn't want to hurt my
feelings or maybe there's an agenda they
want to keep the friendship for whatever
reason how do you know how do you
decipher someone who's just giving you
fluff you mean professionally it's
something that's leading nowhere um
feedback on a script so it could be
a friend it could be a manager somebody
that just they just want to tell you yes
they want to keep you happy but it's
actually not constructive
um
well what i would say is what do you
want from feedback you don't want i mean
of course
our egos need you know a little
attention so when someone says i loved
your script it's so good
there's a second where you appreciate it
because you need validation but then
there's nothing you can do with that and
if you're honest with yourself
you don't really believe that your
script is perfect
and i'm not saying that you should work
on it endlessly because there comes a
time when you have to stop and you have
to move on
and you know there's a fine line
between rewrites and then just over
rewriting it
of course unless you're getting paid and
then you have no choice
what i would say is you you try people
out first of all this intuition i
mentioned right so your intuition says
this person is mindful this this person
might understand what i'm trying to do
you know they're generous with their
time because a lot of people are you
know they can be great individuals
they're not really generous
because you know in order to read
someone's script you need to take
time to read it and take notes
and actually give them something back if
you're just going to read it in a hurry
and and say like oh my god you're such a
good writer great job
you haven't really done the work you
know you haven't really considered i
know my script is not perfect that's why
i gave it to you so um
if you feel people out you try it
usually you know
you know when they give you notes you
know that um if it's gonna work out or
not it's like
you know next time i think i'll go with
someone else
because um
you actually want um honest feedback
like what did you like what did you
connect with
um what's working what's not working
did you find anything um outlandish or
outrageous some people might even i mean
hopefully not but they might even get
offended like why are you offended are
you offended in a good way like is this
you know um
is this
causing contradictions that make you
think or is this actually offensive and
you know i should reconsider it
in terms of topics writer content
um
so i think it's you know trial and error
and with time you find your people with
with the reps um well that's that's a
whole different chapter because reps i
mean
i've had several over the years
and it's it's hard it's almost like a
like a you know like a love relationship
you gotta find your person
and
agent i mean agents you don't expect
much in terms of creative
conversation with with an agent but with
a manager you can
not always though sometimes your
manager's notes might be
you know this is not new enough i need
something new because they're trying to
sell
and it's like well you know i don't
really know what to do with that what
does that mean
what do i know what new is um
so you know that's it's different
because they're not your friend
they can be but i mean
there's mutual interest in that you
produce something that sells and they
want to sell it
but with colleagues and friends i feel
like
you know
you gotta sense it like okay this person
cares this person is generous
and a lot of people are not
unfortunately
you know it's a tricky thing and i don't
mean to contradict what you're saying
but with generosity i think that
especially maybe here in la there are a
lot of takers
and i know that's not a popular thing to
say but i'm just going to say it and so
i think when people they have to be
guarded with their time
yeah that's the only thing i can throw
out about that um well you know i feel
like la's a double-edged sword in the
sense that um you gotta be here because
this is where opportunity happens and
that is still true even though last year
when the pandemic was at its worst i
feel like you didn't have to be here but
usually you do um
with meetings in person at least or
events you know events where you can
actually meet certain people
and that's tricky too because you know
the thing with networking i mean i'm i'm
you know transitioning to a whole
different chapter well the thing with
networking is that you don't just go to
parties and meet someone and get a job
you gotta build a relationship and the
hardest part about la is actually
building meaningful relationships
um and it's about the work
you produce but it's also about a
personal connection that's real
you know people you know when you
actually like someone and they like you
back and you can have dinner and you
don't have to talk about work at dinner
you're just hanging out
but if you you know if you have
something to offer and they actually
like you and you like them
the odds are they're going to call you
so you know it's that
it's not what you do it's who you know
it is about what you do
but um
having a personal connection that's real
doesn't hurt
sure i think that's where
it's a challenge yeah and it is true
look it is it is true that a lot of
people in this town are really desperate
so
they are selfish but also i mean it's
really they're trying to make a living
you know
sorry i'm really trying to be
understanding with everyone like
you can you know get you can get upset
and judge people and think they're
superficial or you know or that their
ambitions
are
um over the top you know but it is a
very competitive environment
and people are just trying to get jobs
so
you know
try to find your people and and if
someone is not
your crowd then that's fine
sure and it's a very expensive place to
live and it's competitive
not just jobs but survival jobs
apartments everything so you're
constantly in this loop of competition
waiting for something and so it's hard
to maybe the generosity it's not that
they don't want to help someone it's
just maybe they're all topped out you
know i mean everyone's here to
quote unquote make it right and
again whatever that means and i say that
because everyone's careers have ups and
downs right and when you're at your
lowest then maybe the next day
things just pick up
incredibly so even for highly successful
people nothing's guaranteed right
you might you know you might be
incredibly successful making a lot of
money and have a deal with uh
amazon or netflix or apple
and then your show is a flop and then
you're vanished right so i
mean it's
it's ups and downs um
[Music]
it's really hard to build meaningful
relationship in a town where everyone's
trying to find their niche and trying to
you know find stability
i'd say that the worst thing about
being a writer or a creator is the lack
of stability
you know we all i think we all crave it
at some point that's why i like teaching
because it gives me a certain stability
and a certain steady income right
um there's nothing wrong with having a
plan b
for the times when things don't work out
um
even i mean even if you have writing
jobs
contract negotiations can take forever
and i'll never understand why because
i'm not involved in that part but
they might take months
so you're waiting on a you know on a
sure thing
and you're going to get paid and you're
going to have you know just have to sit
down right
but
you know reps and lawyers and
there's something going on behind the
curtain that you don't get to see
and you just have to be patient
so either find a hobby or you know
get on a side gig you know i i love
teaching
i love the interaction with students
um
i've you know i've done
educational content i every once in a
while i started out by making film
related
content and then i ended up you know
this year i wrote units on
ethics
and community for example and i didn't
expect that to happen that was exciting
yeah but it's an income it's stimulating
i learn
so
you know you gotta open up like have
different
avenues
open
going back to what you said about
writing and it being hard i i think
you've
posted that you like gorfadall the
author and i know he
he's not worried about uh offending
anyone or just saying what he feels and
um one quote i have here from him is
some writers take to drink
others take to audiences
is there any anything i'm a big fan of
gorvidal i don't know if many people
nowadays
are
um i've read
i mean first of all he's incredibly
prolific i can't believe that man
and by the way he's he's overlooked in
general he's um his whole take on
american history i mean he's
written about many you know
relevant figures and periods of american
history and
he's incredibly
talented and insightful
i especially love his rivalry with
william buckley jr
there's a documentary called best of uh
enemies
and i think aaron sorkin at some point
was going to make that movie and i would
have loved to see that
i just enjoyed it all and
i i envy or i'd say no i admire more
than envy i admire
how
disciplined and prolific he was
in terms of um
you know
writing or any kind of uh stimuli
involved i i'ma get you know i drink
coffee and write you know
uh and in terms of audiences i
i i try not to think too much about that
because
you you know you might you might get
lost thinking about like who am i
writing for
uh you just try to be very
personal and very honest and hope for
the best
that you know just hope that someone
cares
and one last follow-up quote from gord
vidal
the four most beautiful words in our
common language
i told you so
[Laughter]
who i mean look he was he was a pro
contour so i mean i don't know what he
actually means by i told you so which is
probably one of the worst things you can
tell anyone
no one's no one ever reacted well to
that sentence right but um
he did like to provoke a lot um
he liked confrontation
uh
actually you know i think vidal and and
buckley invented the the figure of the
pundit i don't think
before 1968 when they had those
presidential debates
um
journalists you know broadcasting uh
news was just
it tried to be objective the idea of
having someone express opinions and
debate
it wasn't a thing
um
so i think you know i admire vidal as
you know as a novelist
uh as a screenwriter
as a playwright as a pundit
it's just one of those figures that i
i find him
stimulating and i also admire his
intellect